12 candidates are running for the next
french presidential elections in which
48 million people are eligible to vote
with the first round of elections due on
sunday five candidates are seen to be
the main
emmanuel frontrunners is looking for a
second term he has consistently pulled
the highest throughout the campaign
despite only holding his first major
rally last weekend
far-right leader marine le pen is
polling in second place to macon this is
her third presidential run and she has
had a low-key campaign toning down her
usual hard-line rhetoric on immigration
in favor of focusing on household income
and purchasing power
many analysts say a defeat would put an
end to her political career
far left leader jean-luc melenchon is
known as melon show for his charismatic
speeches and firebrand politics
[Music]
has been convicted of hate speech three
times in the past
his poll numbers were high at the start
of his campaign thanks to his
anti-immigration and anti-muslim views
however his campaign has stumbled with
[Music]
foreign
lastly there is valerie pickles from the
traditional right-wing party the
republicans she has had a woeful
campaign run so far and has been snubbed
by former president and party member
nicolas sarkozy the two frontrunners
widely expected to be macron and le pen
will head to the second round of
elections on april 24th but this
election campaign has been marked by a
lack of interest among many from
minorities and the youth and the number
of potential voters who will stay away
is expected to reach a new record